can satanic possession be cured  well if you remove the possessor i guess  so yeah how is that done though  well  biblically it would be through an  exorcism or something of that nature wow  that sounds extremely serious  well  are you demonically possessed  not that i'm aware of do i seem it to  you  no okay  i'm just saying it sounds like an  exorcism is very serious  well  i would say that anyone who's bent on  destroying the human race yeah is  probably in league with the one that you  would say is the enemy of the human race  and that would be satan himself  wow  this is bumming me out mike i'm not  going to lie this is a sad outlook it's  it's it's making me uh sad about about  humanity